but first let me tell you this it is now
a sad reality we're now at the end of a
pretty typical day for Donald Trump and
that is Joe Biden's weaponized doj well
indicted Joe Biden's Chief political
rival once again now this is pretty much
business as usual for Biden's hyper
partisan doj but it's not going to be
our top story tonight we have real
scandals to cover real new news that
nobody else will ever cover and with
legitimate hard evidence of actual
crimes surrounding your sitting
President Joe Biden and what a liar he
has been both as a candidate and as a
president and the amount of money this
family made with absolutely no
experience from the crack addict
prostitute loving son Hunter but first
I'm just being honest okay a quick
message by the way about the Washington
swamp where Trump now does face new
charges uh today and he was a rain today
it's true our nation's capital is
basically a woke swamp dump most uh more
liberal than even San Francisco and New
York combined riddled with crime virtue
signaling Democrats lazy partisan
bureaucrats that we pay for and maybe
worst of all so-called journalists
wouldn't know news of it slap them in
the face in the morning now today those
journalists were out in full force it
was an absolute circus over at msdnc
fake news CNN they're almost giddy
feverishly tracking Donald Trump's every
single move the medium mob wetting their
Collective pants treating this like the
O.J Simpson Bronco Chase Donald Trump
just left Bedminster look right there on
your screen he left that Minster he's in
a car and he's driving and well he's not
he's being driven now at the airport
Donald Trump just arrived at the airport
and he's on his plane he's getting on
his plane his plane is taking off his
plane is landing he's back in the car
there he is they're driving to the
courthouse he pleads not guilty he goes
back in the car he's back in the car
driving to the airport and it goes on
and on and on now of course they obsess
over Donald Trump every second every
minute every hour of every day every
week every month every year but now
they're psychotic infatuation might be
worse than ever according to NewsBusters
now get this pay close attention this is
great between 6 a.m and 4 P.M this past
Monday that was the day that Devin
Archer was giving bombshell testimony on
Capitol Hill about Joe Biden Hunter
Biden the Biden family Syndicate well
msdnc and fake news CNN quote they were
making a combined
759 whopping mentions of
Donald Trump
while the same time mentioning Devin
Archer Amir 48 times they are corrupt
they are abusably biased and they are
blind to their own bias at this point
now on the very same day liberal Morning
Joe mentioned Donald Trump get this a
whopping 70 times in an hour that's more
than once every single minute you don't
believe me we've got the videotape we'll
begin the week with the latest on those
new charges against former president
Donald Trump it also undercuts uh what
had been Mr Trump's defense Trump's
political group we heard from Trump who
can put the words in Donald Trump's
mouth Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump
Donald Trump super Pacs Trump's
political group Mr Trump Trump's Trump
advisors Trump investigation the Trump
situation Trump employee Trump Trump's
Challengers critique of Trump trump
Trump trump Trump's actions Donald
Trump's party and that's Donald Trump
Donald Trump all of Donald Trump's lies
Donald Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump
trumpism I'm Donald Trump with Donald
Trump after Donald Trump trump had the
big crowd in Iowa and he's continuing to
suggest Trump is Trump demanded Donald
Trump is suggesting Trump was impeached
Trump was not chastened by his first
impeachment Trump's allies they're
working towards expunge Donald Trump's
impeachments well Donald Trump that's
former president Trump trouble president
Trump former president Trump of the
looming indictments of Donald Trump and
Trump's Donald Trump's the Trump World
but if Donald Trump's going to call for
it we know that Trump has been a loser
As Trump train Donald Trump Trump's
going to put on this pressure Trump
wants the expungement of his
impeachments for Donald Trump that's
Donald Trump trump Donald Trump Donald
Trump Donald Trump still with a
commanding lead
pretty amazing
so oh by the way I don't dislike liberal
Joe over at Morning Joe I mean but uh
don't you think over there over at the
conspiracy Channel where they lied to
you for three years about Trump Russia
collusion that never happened and you
spread those lies and conspiracy
theories you never apologized you never
corrected the record and you've never
changed your behavior you would think
this obsessive compulsive behavior is
not normal the coverage is totally out
of touch with reality it is insane as
they ignore the big story Joe Biden the
president is being accused of being
actively involved in a bribery Scandal
allegations here to there and everywhere
but that's not news to them where is
your uh journalistic curiosity now keep
in mind shortly after all of that
anti-trump hysteria well Biden's
business partner and friend Devin Archer
was telling Congress all about Joe
Biden's involvement and his son's
sketchy foreign business deals with some
of our top geopolitical foes you know
China Russia Ukraine Kazakhstan Romania
and on and on and on and by the way the
family making tens and tens of millions
of dollars as a reminder to my friends
in the media mob Joe Biden is your
president right now and despite his
glaring weaknesses he is the most
powerful man now it's questionable in
the world he's been caught lying on a
spectacular level both as a candidate
and as your president about I never one
time ever talked to my son hunter or my
brother or anyone for that matter about
their foreign business dealings he said
it as president he said it as a
candidate and it turns out that he was
the brand as Devin Archer said actively
involved in many of these deals without
him his family would not be enriched
with all these tens of millions of
dollars now most so-called journalists
they are ignoring the very real bribery
corruption allegations against him
allegations that he sold out our country
meaning all of us for all of this money
for his family self-enrichment the Biden
brand was critical for this scheme to
work the Joe Biden brand not the brand
of the son Hunter the crack addict Who
Loved hookers not that brand and thanks
to the media's bias of omission half the
country has no knowledge of the
allegations against President Biden we
have a new poll just out tonight sent
over to Me by Matt Towery over at
Insider advantage and it makes sense
half the country does not know the story
about Joe Biden the bribery Scandal
allegations at all the media mob is
covering all of this up and speaking of
which our real top story is that Devon
Archer's transcript was finally released
today from Monday and his testimony we
now know is even more damning than we
originally realized Archer testifying
that Hunter's business strategy was all
about the Biden brand and that Biden
brand was not Hunter but Joe according
to Archer calls meetings with Joe Biden
himself quote brought the most value to
the brand it was Hunter Biden and Him
Father and Son Duo they were a package
Hunter of worthless without his pops
remember what the uh the 1023 form said
Remember the baristma executive quoted
by the credible FBI informant he thought
that Hunter was stupid and that his dog
was smarter than Hunter but hunter
opened a door to his father Joe Archer
also testifying that Barista survived
only because of the Biden brand in other
words without Joe firing the prosecutor
investigating barisma and his son Hunter
he said they would have gone bankrupt he
told Congress that people were
intimidated to mess with barisma legally
because of the company's connection to
Joe that's when Joe leveraged the
billion of your tax dollars to get that
prosecutor fired which by the way ended
up with the Biden enrichment program
continuing for Hunter and by the way the
bidens weren't just selling the illusion
of access as Congressman Dan Goldman
lied to us right after that hearing on
Monday he was lying and according to the
transcripts those were Goldman's words
during questioning a suggestion that
Devin Archer objected to it wasn't just
an illusion these were real meetings
these were real phone calls Joe's
participation was critical to make all
that money Archer himself even received
this delightful handwritten note from
Joey then vice president in 2011. I
apologize for not getting a chance to
talk to you at the luncheon yes
yesterday I was having trouble getting
away from hosting president who and I
hope I get a chance to see you again
soon okay with Hunter pretty weird
letter to Hunter's business partner that
he never talked business with a guy that
claims never once talked about it with
his son none of his farm business deals
but if you only get your news from the
mob in the media you probably won't ever
hear a word about it most so-called
journalists in America today sadly their
Democratic activists they say they're
journalists they are not they are
operating in unison they're an extension
of all things Democratic Socialist Party
they work every day to elect Democrats
beat Republicans and of course as sport
they want to destroy Donald Trump every
second of every day and meanwhile the
Biden's getting a free pass just take a
look at this new Breaking report from
John Solomon he will join us in a minute
that the media mob they'll probably
ignore this too but it's Siri serious
according to John Solomon well we now
have text messages provided to the FBI
that show a massive Energy company
seeking out the Biden brand before
striking a deal in 2017 one of Hunter's
American business partners even boasted
quote there will be a deal between one
of the most prominent families from the
U.S and them China constructed by me hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else